[Music]
[Music]
have you enjoyed yeah okay we have a
little business today that has to do
with the class and then I want to take
off my academic hat and tell you things
that I wish somebody had told me when I
was graduating I won't be able to tell
you all of them unsure because I could
go on for hours with things that I wish
I had been told at some point but we'll
get in as many as we can so let's start
with that which had to do with the class
I promised you a demonstration that you
would remember perhaps forever and then
is very much related to something that
you studied but we'll put a different
light on the effects and we'll talk
about that what we have is a recording
very poor quality but that doesn't make
any difference it was made about 30
years ago in my living room
we had a very we had this eighth of a
sphere which was really well equalized
well designed that by any standard and
we decided to find out what a room
really did to things like the sound we
produced from a loudspeaker or from you
and we made this recording played it
through the loudspeaker put a microphone
in the fountain normal listening
position in your living room took what
wasn't making what was recorded and we
recorded the might and went into the
microphone put it back into the speaker
came through again recorded put it back
into the speaker came through again up
to six times and I think
you'll hear the first time through now
mind you that's sort of like a second
thing through because you're going into
a room and you're not listening over
there falls over the normal modes in
this room aren't the same at the same
frequency so going through the same
system twice is much worse than going
through two different ones but you'll
get the message basically you'll hear
the so-called original and it's a music
first speech next speech sample next and
a pink noise which is the equal energy
per percentage spectrum third and then
you'll hear second round of that will be
after it's going through twice and that
third time you hear it the three great
will have gone through six times now
what I want you to concentrate on is how
each of these sounds deteriorates as it
as it goes through mister process see if
you can't relate the music deterioration
to the speech deterioration to the noise
deterioration and I will put on the
board what seemed like something obvious
to you may not seem so obvious by the
time the demonstration gets at the end I
will put on a little matrix telling
which one is playing so let's go
[Music]
renting a car in essence is no more
complicated than renting one in Miami
Beach the only requirements are an
American driver's license and fifty
dollars down the rental fee is less than
three dollars a day - which is added a
mileage and the cost of gasoline I heard
a Volkswagen and the expense worked out
to a neat $10 per hundred kilometers it
would have been less no doubt if I had
adopted the Greek habit of turning off
the engine on downgrades
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and now the reason for the chart that is
Carmen
[Music]
[Music]
certain similarity of Carmen to speech
[Music]
[Music]
this one
think about strongly it tells the whole
story
[Music]
now I'm sure you know what this is it's
the normal modes you go through a
frequency response once you go through
it twice you square it right cascaded
the same function with itself you get
the square and so it goes each time if
you have a filter that is reasonably
narrowband when you square that thing it
becomes something that's goes way up
here becomes a much higher Q you can
figure out I didn't happen to do it this
term but it's easy to figure out the Q
of these modes of the normal these
normal modes of the room because you
figured out reverberation time already
and that means as you saw in the
derivation that turn on a sine wave in a
room in the decays exponentially well
that's exactly what you would have if
you had a two pole Network and which has
a response that looks like that anyway
and twice this distance is the bandwidth
so twice the decay rate that it decays
at the Alpha there will give you the
bandwidth of the normal modes and
they're pretty high Q and you may not
have noticed or paid attention to the
first time but it took when we got to
the sixth time it took time for the
sound to build up it didn't just start
right on like the original music did it
built up and then when it finished it
died out slowly because the Q of these
filters getting larger each time cause
this fellow bandwidth to get much
smaller and therefore it died out much
much more slowly if you try that same
experiment with other equipment like an
amplifier you go through 40 times and if
you adjust it so that the frequency
response is okay
if it's if it's a few DB down or
something then every time that gets
amplified and and you you will hear it
but if you adjust the frequencies mind
you can go through an amplifier forty
times and not know it except maybe for
noise level and so it's a way of putting
a magnifying glass on what's causing you
the problem
one could argue here and you'll just
have to take our word for it that we
worried about that and paid attention to
it that you're going through two things
yes all the amplifiers and all we
actually did go through all of them
quite a number of times but you're also
going through the loudspeaker but take
my word for it that was what you heard
was not that and it was in fact the
normal modes of the room before changing
completely from the academic side now I
just would like to say a few words with
respect to the what I regard as
excellent performance of the teaching
assistants yesterday just to give you an
idea there was a meeting to discuss
grades now they actually prepared all
the numbers every which way you could
possibly look at them columns and
columns and columns and they a meeting
like this could have lasted 15 minutes
after all the preparation that was done
it lasted five hours because there was
enormous discussion in each case what do
we know about the individual that the
quizzes really represent what that
person knows about the subject did that
person have that particular person have
a really bad time in this in his term in
which the average came down because of
that and all of that only happens when
somebody cares and these teaching
assistants have just like you all the
exams coming up they have a lot to do
and they could have recommended that it
the 15-minute meeting but they didn't so
I have particular thanks to all of them
to lose my do me head teaching assistant
Carlos Cabrera where are you and also a
by the way in terms of hours that they
spent they spent many more hours then
they were either compensated for or
assigned to on this task I hope that
they have I know they enjoyed it I hope
they have learned something and I'm
gonna ask each one of them if they would
like to say a few words in the moment
but there's another person I would like
to acknowledge and that his knee Lac
Ritz who was a teaching assistant in the
subject a few times did a magnificent
job where and he
he'll help out this term with the Bose
people and and the WPI he taught the
same course here at Bose and as I say
you did a fantastic job
last year at MIT and year before that
and here now yes yeah yeah by all means
just gone to pick up his brother at the
well you must have really thank you
thank you thank you just wondered if any
of you would like to just say a couple
of words although since you realize you
better come here maybe here
totally unplanned so I it was a great
experience work does it work it was a
it's an experience teaching I taught
last year and I learned a lot and taught
this year and I learned even more Neal
was my ta when I took it so I've
certainly learned quite a bit from him
as well and it's really quite a pleasure
and all the all the time we put into it
is from my perspective worth it and hope
you feel the same way many of you as
students would be good teacher teaching
assistants and near the end we we'd like
you to sign up if you have an interest
for next year and it's it's a lots of
lots of students who I know sort of
bypass the teaching assistants role
because they wanted to research as dr.
Bose has told us I having been a teacher
and knowing how much I enjoyed and how
much I benefit from it I suggested to
all of you whether you continue with
your studies or not because there's
nothing that teaches you the material
better then teaching and I'll tell you I
was frightfully nervous the first time I
taught and when each time the semester
starts I am nervous also it is I'm sure
much much most of you are at a much
higher level than I am so you just have
to stand up there and be confident and
say no even if you're right
so so thank you I really did enjoy
a lot of what I said it so I agree with
that i mean there's I mean there's
really nothing like teaching job you
really don't know how well you know
something until you have to teach it to
somebody else and like I said it's a
scary experience at first and like Cano
said this is my second time around and
every single time I think I've gone
through this course I've learned just as
much I've learned actually more to think
in teaching in class
that I had as a student learning the
class and it's just I really thought I
mean if you get a chance please do take
the time to teach it's just it's an
incredible experience because not only I
mean do you learn from me I mean I've
learned not only from teaching by
listening dr. Bose and the other
teaching assistants but I learned a lot
from you guys I mean everybody sees
problems in different ways everybody has
their own unique solution to the given
problem and the more I see of that the
more the more amazed the more ways I see
a problem and it's just it's just
incredible so I just like to thank dr.
Bose and the teaching staff and all of
you guys for making this such a great
experience for me thanks
[Applause]
well actually I just want to agree with
Honda serosa
I'd like to add that I was also very
nervous when I started out teaching I
don't think I would have been able to
stand up and talk to you guys unless I
had toured this semester it was an
excellent experience just standing up
and sort of learning from students and
learning from the other teaching
assistants and of course dr. Bose I was
actually taking a number of classes this
semester and it was a very busy schedule
for me but I think this was the most
enjoyable thing that I did this semester
and I don't want to repeat what Harrison
bhishan said but I just like to thank
all of you and teaching staff and of
course dr. Bose thank you very much once
again try teaching if you can and even
if you are taking classes
[Applause]
well she was taking five classes at the
same time I'm gonna tell you guys a
couple of really short stories sort of
anecdotes to sort of illustrate what the
other ta said I can't think of a better
way to make an impact on someone's
career and the path that they're taking
last year when I took the class for a
number of reasons I was having a
difficult time at MIT and that
manifested in all sorts of problems
academically lack of confidence lack of
concentration
I was really doubting myself and the
class you know as it was taught my dr.
Bose really grabbed my interest but even
though I was sitting the lectures in awe
I would go to the problem sets and sort
of I would get stuck I really struggled
with the material and the person who
really helped me out a big time and push
me along and taught me to believe in
myself was Neil LaBute's
I mean he wasn't my ta I just went to
him I said Neil I need some help and he
spent many many hours with me some of
the best advice he gave me was put your
pencil down look at it and think about
what you want to do first and I use that
on every problem now
and if you want to if you want to hear
about how becoming a teaching assistant
can make a difference in your
understanding when I took the exams last
year you guys think you stayed long I
was always one of the last ones to leave
I mean I stayed really really late and I
think I annoyed Neal a couple of times
in doing so but this when this semester
rolled around Hana said look we need you
and oozma to beta test the exam what
coño South got like a full load man I
can't spend six hours like I did last
year no way I mean I can't do it he said
Manish look you know you got to take the
test we need your feedback you're the U
and who's my are the only people that
can really give us an idea of of when
we're there ambiguity is what needs to
be clarified so grudgingly I took the
test from him and I set aside six hours
because I said to myself I'm not going
to spend less than six hours I really
felt that it was gonna take me that long
but after having presented the material
in class after having sat with the
graduate TAS and really preparing the
material I just noticed that in lecture
I began to see things which I struggled
with so tremendously last year things
became conceptualized in a way that I
hadn't been able to think of of problems
before and I mean by inspection the exam
fell apart it really did and it did not
take me what the hell it took me like an
hour or so to get through an exam that
the years prior had taken me like a good
five or six so if you really want to
make a difference in someone's life I
can't think of a better way and if you
want to improve upon yourself I can't
think of a better way Thanks
[Applause]
well I have to say that I agree with all
this now I'm not going to repeat what
they say I think the basic idea has been
communicated that if you think you know
something you really didn't learn as
much as with it I just want to thank all
of the teaching assistants they have
been of great help I mean I I couldn't
have done it without their help and
their support all the time and I want to
thank my students for teaching me so
much Thanks
[Applause]
I just want to take a minute to thank
dr. Bose he's the first person I've ever
met
who cares so much about teaching and
he's the man who taught me everything I
know about how to communicate
information and how to teach to people
so thank you very much okay so much for
the academics no we go on yes oh oh I'm
sorry I did not I was not connected to
that and I'm very very sorry
[Applause]
what faces you in the future is
something that most of you don't expect
and yet statistically it's a absolute
fact if you look at the alumni records
you will be amazed at the dispersion of
professions that students enter that
have in fact many cases nothing to do
directly with what they spent there for
five six seven years studying it even in
this country those people who go into
engineering the average time spent by a
u.s. graduate in engineering in the
field if he assumed that he
there's the field that he was trained
for the average time that he spends
there is seven years in Japan by the way
it's 20 but different here many things
happen some good some bad in many
companies I think it's somewhat
unfortunate but their reward for good
performance is to make the person a
manager and all too often you get a you
lose a wonderful engineer and you get a
terrible manager but there are many
reasons why this happens but you should
be prepared for this and even if you
don't even begin in the field that you
were trained for hopefully your
education will enable you to get to the
top that's what education should be all
about because the facts that we may
teach you will be totally irrelevant if
you don't enter that field and will be
mostly irrelevant if you do because they
will change they will evolve you will
develop new things and so faxer have
little importance the thought process is
everything and as these changes come
don't feel that you are my god you know
thank you I've wasted four years or five
or six years whatever it is that's
that's not the case as I think I
mentioned in class once they they head
of surgery at Mass General Hospital
there's an MIT grad so you all have a
chuckle if I tell you which course Amy
had nothing to do with his skill with a
scalpel basically he'll tell you what
his education did for him at MIT is
invaluable in the way he thinks so what
I think I'm going to do is take you
through some highlights to get you to
appreciate some things about your career
as they come along and if you'll excuse
me I will do this in a way that I think
is most believable I don't want to stand
up here and preach to you and and and
have you one there hour and maybe this
is your words or what not so I will use
some personal examples here and I don't
think I'm a typical these same things
have happened to a lot of people in
different forms but it's more believable
if it comes from somebody about himself
so I'll spend a little time on that and
then we'll get to things some of the
other topics I want to get to like how
do you go out job shopping and how do
you get creativity really rolling well
I'd like to illustrate some changes that
come along that will come along with
high probability in your lives that that
you may not like and we'll talk about
what you can do about them when I
finished my Master's here I went over to
Phillips to work for Holland for the
summer and I had arranged the doctorate
thesis and conformal mapping with Gilman
by the way this group is different than
just the MIT class so some of you will
have heard parts of this but I'll try to
make that short and I came back about a
week or two late but I had this thesis
all arranged and a research
assistantship and I knew that food would
be on the table because the research
assistantship was there and I came
rolling into building 20 and went to my
desk and there was a little note on the
desk
it said please see the director of the
laboratory research laboratory of
electronics so I picked it up and I went
in that was dr. Jerome Wiesner who was
later President Kennedy's science
advisor and
and president of MIT but he was head of
the research laboratory RLE
that exists today and so he and the
assistant director were there and I sat
down and wondered why I was asked to
come in there since there they had
nothing to do with my thesis except I
was working in that laboratory but the
thesis was all theoretical in any case
and so they told me the story about
Norbert Wiener
and I also wondered why they were
telling me that story and then it came
down to the fact that they thought
Norbert Wiener had some things that were
really applicable in electrical
engineering and they've been thinking
this he had a number of them over the
decades but they thought he had some
material more recently that they really
wanted to get to transfer into
electrical engineering and then they
said that look we have tried three
doctorates on this program and they
didn't write but we think that there's
something there still and then came the
bombshell they said we would like you to
work on this I was and I thought maybe
they didn't know you know that I have a
research assistantship I have a
professor that I thought the highest of
and I'm very happy so I explained that
immediately and they said yes we know
but we would like you to work on this
and I was really annoyed at this point
because it was a totally different field
I had taken a minor in math but you know
to work for Norman Weiner with a minor
in math is like you know studying
calculus when you don't know arithmetic
so I listened and I finally said look
are you drafting me and they said yes
it's the only time I know of anybody
being drafted to do a doctorate thesis
and then they could see the shock on my
face at this point and they said well
that's look if you don't like it after a
year you come back and we'll let you go
back to the thesis you wanted to do and
so
I was what 23 at the time and I was
really really upsetting
so I said look if you're not going to
give me a choice I'm not going to come
back into this office in one year and
start over if this is my only choice
here I go so I went out and and they
told me that I had to have a nominal
supervisor and electrical engineering
because I was in EE and so that this
would be professor white Y W Lee so I
went to see him and I said look I will
see you in a year or two I've got to go
in the math department and study math
since I've been assigned this project he
says no no no no so he gave me whole
pile of must have been about fifty pages
or so of of tight mainly equations and
said you just read this I read it twice
a day for about six months and it didn't
make any sense at all so I started to go
over to the math department and library
and read anything that I thought was
related I wasn't even sure what was
related to this mathematics I started
reading everything I could and I kept
coming back to Lee and telling him wrong
this is I don't even know anything about
this and this is ridiculous and he
didn't know anything either and so he
just kept saying don't worry it'll come
I did this went on until about February
started in September went on till
February and then Lee came into my
office one day and said oh by the way he
said there's going to be a International
Conference of mathematicians here at MIT
this summer in June and you're you're
you are to speak on wiener theory
at this point I really literally came to
the point where you have these dreams
where you have somehow you've wound up
in class in grade school and you forgot
to get dressed it was just a hard
experience and I never went to see
Weiner during all this period because
what could I say that I don't understand
we're about the only words I could utter
to Norbert Wiener that's all I know
I bait to get out of this thing this
presentation because these were the top
mathematicians from the world we're
gathered in this as I was told and and I
begged him to get out of this and no no
don't worry don't worry it'll come so I
kept reading this thing twice a day
twice a day you read it day and night
and tried to get my mind off of the fact
that I couldn't understand it because if
you focus on something like that you're
dead if you think you cannot do
something you will not do it so you've
got to get your mind you happen you're
gonna bump into problems like they get
the kind of a thinking out of your head
because that is an absolute block to to
any kind of progress so I kept going
kept going and I gave up on visiting Lee
after about four or five times as I look
he's just gonna tell me
keep at it it'll come just two weeks
before
one afternoon I read it and oh by the
way I found some mistakes as I was
beginning to get the little
understanding I could I could understand
enough in these huge integral equations
that there was some errors least I
thought there were so I went to him I
said you know this seems like there's
some errors he said oh I didn't I forgot
to tell you he said this was typed from
the back of envelopes that Norbert
Weiner had scratched on in Paris by a
secretary that didn't type English
little own masks
and so he said you can expect some
errors at least I thought well you know
maybe I'm getting to the level where I
didn't see the errors well just two
weeks before the the conference was to
start I rented one afternoon buying it
everything became crystal clear just
absolutely clear and I really sat back
that night and I said my god Isley a
professor or a prophet I mean he had
this seemingly incredible confidence and
conference began and I got up there it
was the first time I had talked publicly
and oh my god I mean my god dry I was so
nervous in the first couple of minutes I
and this audience out there and it
wasn't survive and but after about two
or three minutes of that everything came
back and he started going and was fine
until somebody raised their hand what
happens when you're in the front of a
group and somebody raises their hand the
first thing you see is the hand then you
follow it down and guess who was
connected and I thought at that point it
was all over I mean if there had been a
panic button and a hold and podium I
going straight through it he asked the
question and I was so nervous I couldn't
even to the question I thought I had it
I answered it incorrectly and very
calmly very politely he said exactly the
same thing you didn't say you didn't
answer it or anything else he just went
through the same question again and
somehow it got to me and I calmed down
and I was able to answer it with great
fortune and then don't think turned I
mean I went on through the presentation
just no problems at all like I've been
teaching for years and then at the end
of the whole conference they had all the
mathematicians fill out a form relative
to the value of the
whole two-week conference etc and when
they leave walked into my office and he
said maybe you'd like to know that your
presentation was voted to be the best
and I thought what was inside and also a
mathematician it turns out that you can
do things in other fields you really can
that made a huge difference in my life
because when I realized for the first
time that GU could come to the to a
level in another field that you didn't
know anything about a year ago with
intense effort to be sure and a lot of
time spent but it gives you whatever
that happens it gives you a confidence
that you are now on another plateau and
you're ready to go up again and it takes
away a lot of the fear that you would
have had I went through more fear in
that year than you could ever imagine
and that started a 10-year relationship
between Norbert Weiner and I in which we
met almost every day and it was
something that everything I've ever
earned could never even begin to pay for
well when I graduated or when I was
doing the final you know thesis exam
weasoner
Jerry reason it was one of the examiners
and after the exam it was over in the
math department and I think it was and
we had a long way to walk back to
building 26 and he asked me what am i
doing well it turned out that in
February of the year I was going to
graduate in June and in February Norbert
Wiener had said to me at that time by
the way I my frame of mind was I
couldn't wait to get out the industry
and get a research job I had studiously
avoided all forms of teaching I knew
that was the one thing that I never
to do and so I was certain of that and
and all teaching assistantship no word
of any interest and I always wanted to
research and I lived on that and then
and I couldn't wait to get out there to
do it and February of January of that
year that I was going to graduate nor
the leaner when they said you know bows
your heritage is from India you should
spend a year there apply for a Fulbright
well if anybody else in the world had
said that to me I would have fought them
tooth and nail but I had come to respect
him so highly by that time I found
myself saying all right without even
thinking I mean if my parents have told
me that or anybody else I thought oh God
but no because I was afraid of spending
any time away from this that you your
level would go down without exercising
the math and whatnot and so I found
myself just like that saying alright and
I did it but then a couple months later
I got worried I said you know suppose
I'm applying for this thing now and
suppose I don't get it oh boy the end of
the line comes in June I don't have a
job and I have no income so I went to
Lee and I professor Lee and I told them
this is a problem you know I I think I
better start going out interviewing just
to back this thing up with the same
confidence that he says don't worry
don't come he said don't do that he said
Norbert Wiener is writing the
recommendation I took him for his word
and so but at the graduation in June
coming out of the exam Jerry Wiesner
said to me he asked me what I was doing
and I told him the whole story I was
going to India for a year and that I was
gonna use the summer to make certain
that I found the job I want in industry
so that the minute I come back I'm all
set and he said well what about teaching
as I explained to him that why I didn't
want anything to do with that and so we
walked a few more paces down Carter and
he said in those days you used to have
to be an inch
a teaching assistant and then an
instructor and then faculty and so he
said bull look suppose we would bypass
these things and put you on the faculty
and I said well you know thank you very
much but I don't want anything to do
with teaching and I know what I want I
want research and that ended the
conversation and then I walked a little
further and I thought you know they were
so kind to offer all this maybe I could
ask for something I really wanted I said
could I stay in the summer I have a
little money saved from the research
assistantship I can live and could I
stay with no salary
I just bought a loudspeaker and then the
thing measured very well and it sounded
horrible and I want to find out why and
if I could stay here and use your
equipment I don't want a salary but I do
would like would like to use the
anechoic chamber and equipment and he
said absolutely no problem so that was
the end of the conversation and I did
that and that started to change my
career sort of but but the another
change I never expected to be in this
area but then I a week or so before a
week at the two weeks before the plane
was to leave in September I was in the
pool at MIT and I was coming to the end
of the lane and somebody I don't
remember who I think it may have been
thomas Stockham digital fame today what
he reaches harm over the edge of the
pool and and said congratulations and we
went through a big thing it seemed to be
interminable it must have lasted a
minute or so well for what no you know
what no I don't
finally he was convinced I didn't know
what and so he said well he said they
catalogs the four catalogs out and
you're on the faculty with the leave of
absence for the first year and another
minute or so he sort of convinced me it
was true so when I was in the shower
room and changing I decided what to do
about this strange thing and I decided
before I left the pool that I would do
it for two years and I read fully afraid
of absence then I would be three years
I'd go away one year in two years and I
thought oh my god I'll be done as far as
research goes because then the faculty
there's so many duties that I don't have
the time that I wanted that and so I
went to leave I never even I didn't know
who to go to and I went to lis and I
said you know I've been told that this
thing is in the catalog and and you know
I think I'll do it for two years well as
far as I know to this day there's never
been a any agreement between MIT and
myself I did it I didn't even know how
much I was going to get until I came
back and at the end of the first month I
think I there was a pay cheque so I
decided to do it only for two years then
what happened was something that I
didn't realize until a couple of years
ago what changed that and it was in the
second term I was teaching a course in
statistical theory of communication grad
course and it was big grad course and it
was another professor teaching it who
had been a teacher of mine and being a
junior I had to do all the sorting of
the of the cards that came in and what
and they were out of about 50 students
they were three or four of them who said
on their card no offense but I would
like to Professor someone so he was a
very good teacher and well you know when
you read that it one feeling is sort of
it hurts you but the next minute you
realize look you know he's very well
known he is a good teacher and the
student was very polite about saying no
offense but I would like that person
well what went through my mind then and
I never realized that this is what
changed my decision until just a couple
of years ago for some reason I had to
give a talk for an or between oh it was
even more recent had to give a talk at
the Senate an area of his birth what
happened was I said to myself and I
remember that know that that you know
one day I'm gonna try to become such a
good teacher that that students might
say no offense to somebody else they
would like to have me and saying that
was a commitment because you weren't
gonna achieve that in one more year by
any means so that's what happened and so
I went into that marked into the
classroom and I was a professor by
definition didn't know anything about it
and had to try to learn what it meant to
teach but found it interesting and found
it interesting to to the extent that
this was 1957 when I got back to the
extent that when patents had issued in
electronics and
and acoustics and it came time that MIT
had to decide what they were going to do
with these if they take them at that
time and maybe the same now that you get
12% of the royalties that they get if
they decide not to take the patents they
give them to the faculty well they gave
them to me and I these were patents and
electronics and switching amplifiers and
other patents and an acoustics so I
thought ah now I by this time I really
realized I wanted to stay at MIT so
that's licensed these patents so my
former roommate at MIT had going on to
Harvard and become a patent attorney and
and so he started to try to license
these with absolutely no lot to talk
because the acoustic patents were useful
for the for the home and the electronics
patents at that time were only useful
for a government because they were high
efficiency power processing and
amplification kinds of devices that were
very expensive light weights very very
small I mean you could we demonstrated
the 20 watt amplifier that was only that
big you've seen more better than that
now and so he was getting absolutely
nowhere and one daily professor leader
it was a very very cultured Chinese
gentleman and he brought me into his
office and he sat me down and he said I
would like out of the blue he said I
would like to tell you about my time
during the War World War two
in China no idea why he wanted to do
this we know when we talked about
technical things so he started and he
said I I could see that there was a war
coming within 39 or something in the
Japanese were coming in and and he said
I felt he was a professor he had
graduated under Norbert Weiner gone back
to teach in and then what was Peking and
he decided he'd better get out of the
country so he came and he was very
conservative person he came three days
to Shanghai before the ship came
and he told me about this and the next
day that after he arrived in his hotel
the Japanese arrived and so he never got
out of that hotel for the duration of
the war out of it meaning to continue
his journey and he had to survive
because the money that he had wasn't
adequate to keep him in the hotel so he
became from a professor of Electrical
Engineering he became a curio dealer and
he decided to tell me all about the
curio business and I'm still wondering
you know why why is he telling me all
this and but I knew him from the past
he always had a vision it was a little
bit further and so he described that
they go up to the hills and they they go
to the farmers and and the farmers dig
up many things just in plowing that are
curios that are of value they take him
to town and they market them that's what
he did and it's a tough business he was
reduced to a string bean literally I saw
pictures of it was like a walking
skeleton at the time but in any case he
carried on his business and then he told
me he said you know what the dream of a
carrier of the Illyria's he said it has
two parts first part is that one day
they will go up to the hills and an
article of great value will come into
their heads
somebody digs up something that really
is valuable second part of the dream is
that they will recognize the value and
not just pass it through as another
curio and then he said that's all I
wanted to tell you shut me out but that
was the end of the discussion and I went
home and thought about it and it was
pretty clear what he was really saying
to me without ever mentioning it was
look you're trying to license something
you have the curio in your hand
very valuable and you're trying to
license it be careful so I came back in
the next day and I told him I I said I
thought about what you told me and I
understand and then he and I and then
Sherman joined who was my student at the
time and we had numb and then my former
roommate who had gone to Harvard and we
had a number of sessions about once a
month blind leading the blind absolutely
about forming a company none of us said
maybe one had read of PML once but I
certainly hadn't and what what should we
do which of these patents should we go
after and all this and that and it was
me literally I mean it would think would
make a comedy strip if you if it had
ever been
tape recorded but that is finally what
led to the company know what happens in
life is that you don't many cards which
you don't expect you get changed in your
career from one thing to another there
are some people who doesn't matter
whichever way that appointed they go
after it with gusto and they rise to the
top and there are some people who spent
a good deal of their life moaning and
complaining that they were Delta a poor
head I'm convinced not only from my own
experiences but but from watching many
many people over the years that there is
no bad hat you can optimize almost
anything you set your mind to and you
all have a phenomenal training with that
training your probability of success is
very high and the jobs that you get will
be not what is given to you but what you
make of it I'll give you an example I
should say two examples for a number of
years I supervised the course 6a
students in
to companies General Electric and Philco
and it was a belly Ford Space Center in
general record and they went through a
very bad period in the 60s where they
had Skybolt contract was cancelled and
they have a contract with them mighty
thick the 680 companies they have to pay
MIT so much and once they signed this
thing and they have to take a certain
number of students well they were in a
very embarrassing position because they
had to take these students that they had
no work for so they did and it was my
turn to go down and visit the students
that went down and first student came in
they were good students were two of them
first student came into the office and
he said oh this is how you said this is
ridiculous he said I want out of this
subject you know what he said they lost
the contract this guy boat contract they
don't have any work to do
my boss has been violated and he said
you know what they have me doing so they
have me sitting at the end of an
assembly line and plugging these
transistors into a socket as they come
down and I see that the light is green I
put them in one back and if it's red I
put them in the other back and he said
this is stupid stuff and he said I want
out of this program and I got both
barrels I'll tell you and so there was
no work the boss really had been fired
so you know I said look I'll do the best
I can but I have all your inputs now and
we'll we'll see what we can do and then
I had a few minutes before if the next
the other boy came in and I looked over
his file
ooh boy he was even a better student so
I thought oh god here we go
I'm really gonna get it this time and so
he came in and I didn't say anything I
just well how was he going and he said
well he said you know that was the
contract and my boss has been fired
and they're laying off people left and
right around here and he said you know
but this is the most worthwhile term
I've ever had done this he said this has
been phenomenal for me
what's people what is going on I they
said well he said you know what they
have me doing know I'm sitting at the
end of an assembly line just deuce in
there and he said if the lights green I
put him back and then he said but you
know what I did is I went to the
management and I asked him if the ones
that go in the red bag namely the bad
ones I could take home and they said
sure they're gonna throw them out and he
and he said I bought a microscope and I
bought some tools to section these
transistors and I watched and tried to
learn what was causing the defect and he
said in this term I have learned so much
that I would not have learned that MIT
that I would not have learned are there
other conditions at the job he said it
is been the best experience and work
that I have had and I then thought oh my
god look at this same exact job one I
enjoyed it
not the actual transistor but the whole
experience and he learned an enormous
amount from it and the other one looked
at it as if I'd been dealt a bad hand
somebody else gave me the business and
what a hell of a position this is and
that was my most vivid lesson of the job
is what you make it
and you can take I can't think of too
many things that you might be dealt in
your life in the terms of jobs that
are in some sense worse than what this
person okay what was given but look at
the difference and I somehow wish today
I could follow those two and find out
what their relative progress in life has
been I and I think you can bet which one
has really really risen so I've always
found in in this company as well that
they're the people who just don't have
the excitement or interest and complain
about what they're doing you can they
think they're gonna do something else
you put them in that direction and then
sometimes it works but usually it
doesn't and if they're really best
people are ones who you could come up to
them today and say look we've really
need you who were going in this
direction to go in that direction by God
they will go in that direction and they
will come to the top I've seen it where
technology is involved
we're just businesses involved they grab
the vocabulary of the field apply their
thinking and they go at an enormous rate
and with enormous quality and so it's my
feeling that a good person you can spin
him around in any direction which he
ends he will just pursue with excellence
and we all have the ability to do that
and that's before I talked a little bit
about how you can unlock how I believe
you can unlock some of that I'd like to
just give you some of the examples that
some of you who have heard the talk that
I gave in Stand and Deliver and
deduction and it's it's we'll hear some
duplication but they were really in
summary three major experiences in my
life that convinced me of something that
if I could convince you of in the next
ten minutes I would be so happy because
I know it's true namely that every one
of you has ability in proportions that
are enormous compared to what you
believe and what you've ever used and
the first experience that that that
really drove that home to me was Norbert
Wiener because he in those 10 years of
association we did projects together
that covered all sorts of things they
including the Boston arm that which
works from your brain and whelmed us up
in operating theaters that in Mass
General Hospital a lot of which by the
way has never been published because we
were scared stiff you know they're the
people that what we did is the surgeons
and my I was the head of this group at a
Harvard MIT and Mass General and the
surgeons were from Harvard and if people
needed a operation that would involve
their arm like they had in neuroma or
they needed an older transplant through
the calcification we would tell them
look we will give you the operation free
if he will allow us to make some
experiments which won't hurt you we
wanted to study what was actually
happening in the nerves and what you
could measure and we'd ask these people
who had no arm for example to to move
their first finger and their little
finger and their thumb make believe they
had on and had an arm or if it was an
older transplant plant they actually did
and we wanted to study the nerve
transmission so that we could make this
arm as realistic as possible working
from the brain and we didn't publish it
because when everybody was scared stiff
that some a mule in chasing lawyers
would go to one of these patients later
and say suggests that he had a headache
and that the headache was due to this
and you could get him millions of
dollars as you can see from the
advertisements of many lawyers
television in any case in this process
before we ever got near the operating
theaters we had many discussions I think
it was every week in in Mass General and
after a couple of months in this on one
break every nervous out of the room and
the surgeons who top of orthopedics at
Mass General rushed over to me and said
law said you know we have heard that
Norman Weiner has no medical training
but you can see in these last couple of
months every single time we make the
simplest error or a complicated error in
anatomy he interrupts in corrections and
he is always right now tell us what
actually where did he go
and he never had a day's training in
this but he knew every bit of anatomy
like like the medical journals never
mind like a person and he had the
ability to do anything that passed
before his eyes or his ears went in Carl
Wiles professor Wiles Electrical
cheering took him to in 1936 took him to
Gilbert and Sullivan production and
everybody knew weiners reputation from
the time he was 25 on and and so Wilde's
came out said how is it that do you
remember I mean it look at what do you
want
and he named a piece and you know
Gilbert and Sullivan he goes so rapidly
you can barely understand it and right
through word-for-word
just once in that's all you needed well
Wiener really I don't know if he made it
a point he must have he worked on me for
10 years to get me to understand and
believe that everything he was was a
result of his father's upbringing which
he resented all his life by the way but
he said without that I all the things
that I
that people think that I'm a genius for
would not it would never have developed
his father was a professor of languages
at Harvard and two professors at the
turn of the century decided to bring up
geniuses if I shortcut the story that's
what they decided to do and Weiner at
the age of five or six was already
reciting Iliad and Odyssey
from memory in Greek he knew nine
languages he by the way he learned to
read write and speak Chinese in the six
months that he spent in China and in
somewhere 3637 timeframe and professor
wilds went over there the next year and
had the same teacher and and Wiles told
me said every time he'd go for a lesson
the teacher would say now I'm normally
demeanor he was a good student so all of
this ability came when the father the
way the father brought him up which was
as Wiener felt a terrible terrible thing
he used to have to stand beside his
father every night while the father was
correcting work for Harvard and the
father diffic nord him until he made the
simplest error in anything and then in
verbally reduced him to dust it was a
terrible terrible experience and then at
six years old he was told by the doctor
that his eyes were finished and that
they would be totally finished if he did
not stay away from reading for a year
now the two professors were competing
and they were doing pretty well
according to their finisher by this time
so they decided the father have decided
look that's no excuse that's just that's
a problem you have but experiment and he
forced him to do everything in his head
and Weiner told me that when he was
seven years old he has a seven year old
recognized that the whole world had just
changed in his vision that he could do
things that he couldn't dream of at the
age of six and he could recognize that
at seven years old he could do his math
you have to do everything in his head
his math and in his head and he went on
and he got his bachelor's degree from
Tufts at 14 the first of two doctorates
at 18 and the other fella did exactly
parallels to Weiner it was a very
interesting thing the fact and the only
thing was that the other one at 22 said
the hell with it all and became an
accountant he just decided to wanted a
different track in life but Weiner kept
on but he had an insecurity as a result
of that that was enormous I mean he'd go
to these conferences and he come to me
afterwards how do they do how do they do
now my god you know I understood only a
certain percentage 42 what he was
talking about but he have to be told he
was okay he never really he never really
had the confidence but he had the power
that was so enormous and what he
convinced me and I have to believe he
made a real effort over those years
because he said it in so many ways so
many times that everybody has this
ability we all come with it we just
don't believe it and we don't develop it
nobody develops it for us we're already
getting near what how much more spend
too much time on this ok so what that
experience was one then I won't go into
the other ones in any detail now because
what I didn't realize how much time has
been the the other one was I as a result
of that experience with Weiner when I
was asked to teach our major course
right after that in electrical
engineering the first introductory
course in network theory my idea was to
see it what you could do if you got them
not at the cradle but it might
or 18 years old what did you do and I
spent seven years to experiment with
that and then it grew to be a subject
that was taken by a lot of different
courses included a third of the
Institute when he was only a 25% and the
students were all did they work but they
worked voluntarily I used to have a
meeting with all the section
representatives in fact your father was
one of that section representatives and
me I would tell the students now look
you tell your section representative
when you've got enough this is an
exciting subject I want to give you more
homework and I'm gonna raise it until
you tell the section represented that's
enough and I'll stop well he got up to
15 hours a week homework in the 12 hours
subject and hope this isn't being video
recorded me I lost my nerve at that
point how can you possibly get 15 hours
home working 12 hours a day I didn't so
I stopped at that loving 15 well they
worked and I can tell you the end result
that the faculty this was a different
way of teaching the subject but the
faculty is where tutorials all started
off - I used to give the quiz to the
faculty and I had 30 I had my total pick
of the faculty at that time and I picked
the most senior ones whose reputation
wasn't on the line in there and the
rules for the tutorial where no faculty
preparation students can ask whatever
they want in the general subject area
and I hope the faculty get stuck and I
would announce that to both of them
because I want them to see Wiener had
put into me that look if you ask anybody
of his generation in mathematics where
you graduated from you will only show
your ignorance that's not important you
ask them who did they graduate under and
I really thought about that you know he
graduated second doctorate was under
hardy and Cambridge and boy you look at
the mathematicians who graduated under
there's something there's something
about that their pattern of operation
and thinking and everything that this
come and what it is is they got to work
with a very experienced person who
didn't know the answer to the problem on
the doctorate and they go down the blind
alleys back up come over to a another
approach why did they go this way
instead of a thousand other ways
something of that process which none of
us know how this day and age to teach
runs off and so I wanted to have this
faculty and students have a chance in
groups of four to one with the senior
faculty two to experience that what
happens and just tell you one result it
happened actually place but in it was
Professor wilds again who was one of
very senior teachers at the time he was
leading one of the tutorials and he
walked in somebody asked a question that
really stumped him right off the bat he
turned to the board he was working on in
about ten minutes had gone by he got
nowhere and one boy who had not spoken
this was four weeks into the term sort
of timidly raised his hand and said sir
couldn't you do the following thing
Wilde's turned around with the board did
it zip right to the answer and then he
was just like his reputation wasn't on
the line he was a senior person and he
turned around he told the truth he said
no I was up there ten minutes and he
said I was trying to solve the problem
but he said what was in the back of my
head was glass suppose I'm up here at
the end of the hour and he said I'm
trying to get those thoughts out and try
to devote myself to the problem but he
said one thing I'm certain of if if I
had come up with a solution I would not
have realized such a direct approach he
said that just wasn't in my thinking
that said this is about the most direct
way you can go well it turns out he
didn't know nor did I know that that boy
who timidly raised his head he knew that
the end had spoken in the first four
weeks he was the one out of the four
that hadn't spoken he was on academic
probation
to be thrown out at the end of that turn
well it turns out that in six week was
the first quiz then there was the second
one and the third one in the final he
got 100 in the second quiz first place
second place third quiz and the final
exam he was top of 300 students at MIT
he soared off of this probation all his
subjects picked up and he just sailed
through MIT
now nobody educated that person in those
few moments they only unlocked the key
that made the fellow believe that Jesus
dummy
I not only solved the problem the
professor admitted he couldn't solve but
he told me that I solved in the more
direct method than he would have he
heard something he believed all of a
sudden in himself and that was the key
did took off for and I've seen that
happen so many times in different ways
with people in MIT outside of MIT some
key turns the person around and they go
after that so what I really really want
you to to understand is that you all
have that and if you can believe it I
mean I wish I had more time than the
last part the way was the Escalante but
most of you have heard me give the
introduction which he takes people who
are selling drugs who could give a darn
and their parents give a dime for
arithmetic and turns them into scholars
that go on through calculus chemistry
physics everything and just if I could
get you to believe that that's there and
when things get rough and they will and
you life is somewhat of a yo-yo it
presents problems that are really
depress you at times and and you get
pretty high and things at other times by
the way in since I'm having to cut a lot
of it short now one thing I would
you is that concentrate on getting your
satisfaction in life from what you think
about what you've done not from what
others think what other thing is fickle
it goes up and down all the time you see
this actors have great depression when
the format of popularity sports people
go through the same thing because
they're looking for the there their
satisfaction from others those of you
that learn to get it from yourself you
know everybody has some measure inside
of them when they're doing well and when
they're not and if you get that
satisfaction from when you are doing
something well that is lasting and it is
the only form that will really help you
and then it's really exciting and
there's nothing like having done
something and worked and worked and
worked on it let's say it's research
that which excites me and get a result
finally you and Malika many many many
blind alleys and you finally get
something that satisfaction is enormous
and there's another degree of it which
shouldn't be order dis if what you were
trying to do was impossible was thought
to be impossible by others you get more
satisfaction so if you're doing
something that you're working on that
there's thought to be impossible in fact
Escalante in his classroom has this big
sign that he painted and it says if you
think something is impossible
do not disturb the person who is doing
it good good thinking
now they laughed I'm really gonna cut
short here they the other thing I would
like to just tell you very quickly about
looking at a job you heard a lot of it
from our people today look for the
people that you're gonna be working with
very important because what you will be
will be a reflection directly of the
people that you come in contact with
it's their high level you will do better
seeing when you pick a
you pick a school really the way to do
it is pick to school with the highest
level of students in it
because that causes you to rise to meet
the that level and that is extremely
important the other thing is look at the
character as well as the ability of the
people when you go interviewing you ask
a lot of questions it this whole
business of job going for a job is like
having the permission to have one date
and then after the date you've got to
decide if you're going to get married
and what happens with the one date you
have both on your best behavior and so
the company that you're interviewing is
on the best behavior because they are
looking for somebody and you're on your
best behavior because you want to show
them that you're the person they're
looking for and you learn very little do
a few things that won't be expected by
the companies you're interviewing but
for example you spend a lot of time -
the person takes you around ask them
what their history is in the company
when they joined it and what happened to
them how they view it then get down to
asking what are the three things you
like the most and what are the three
things you like the least pay attention
to the first one than what you like the
least
that's usually the thing it's central in
their head and when you get interviewed
by people ask them that it's alright no
problem with asking questions and
they're not prepared for that but you
will see that like in any company there
are advantages and disadvantages and you
want to have a balance you want to
understand that so don't worry about
asking those kind of questions what do
you like what are the three things you
like the most about the company we're
three things you like the least about
the company you get a very good idea
look for the character as well as the
technical ability of the people you're
going to work with very very important
unfortunately there's a heck of a lot of
in this world very poor ethics that
extend through corporations also many
I wonder if it's not most corporations
if you are caught up in something like
that your ethics your principles will
change in the wrong direction directions
that you wouldn't like them to change
but it will happen
so watch those elements as much as you
can and then the other the last thing I
will say very quickly about companies is
you will encounter in every organization
not just companies whether you join a
church or whether you join an industry
you will encounter politics of people
and that perhaps well I can't say a
priori I mean you're either going to be
part of the solution you're gonna be
indifferent to it which is pretty hard
or you're gonna be part of the problem I
hope it's not that it happens usually
with weak people who for protection for
security build an empire and they build
this with you want to say intrigue I
know what you want to call it but but
they build a protection around they
usually bring weak people in around also
because they will be shown up by a
strong person these kinds of things are
the essence of what can destroy not only
the work but but the people whether we
think of it you probably haven't thought
about this but most of the waking hours
that you will have in life will be in
some way associated with work being
there going to it coming from it
thinking about it you can't help it and
it's true for almost everybody in
professional field is very true you
can't turn the switch off at five
o'clock or whatever it is and if that's
a pleasant experience your life will be
but very pleasant if it's a bad
experience you'll be going through life
in a way that you really shouldn't maybe
you've heard the story of the beggar who
sat on the corner and there was a
well-dressed businessman who he noticed
was rushing by every morning at a
certain time one morning
the businessman was going a little
slower and so bigger got up and thought
he maybe could interrupt them and he
said sir I see you going here every day
what are you doing and they said I'm
going to work Vegas is why and he says
sorry get her money bigger says one well
so I can I can save this and I can
retire and why do you want to retire
said so I can do what I want
bigger said Jesus that's what I'm doing
now
so don't go through life trying to focus
on what you're gonna get that'll make it
comfortable go through life making
everything you do everything do
interesting to you and you will perform
you will perform very very well I've
always found that the people who come
into a company in one position or power
or money their focus is so much on that
that the creativity part usually doesn't
come along
the people who are totally excited about
what they're doing creativity just
bubbles out and if they're in the right
corporation my god they get recognized
they never have to blow their horn
the good ones never never ever have to
blow their horn know one last thing I
Bethenny's creativity the the best way
to get this going
Einstein had this theory that and I
really believe that that the mind has
many levels it's capable of working on
problems at all these different levels
and it fires to the equivalent of an
output register when you have an idea
and that's when you get a flash and you
think oh boy then you spend a long long
time trying to all the tools that you've
learned justified that that thing really
works and the real question comes the
exciting thing comes how do you get that
mind going on those different levels and
I believe there is a very definite way
to do that a very definite way and that
is whatever your job is
you decide that you're going to do it
better than it's ever been done by
anyone else or yourself in the minute
you have decided that that's what you're
going to do what happens is you
immediately like a sponge you learn
what's been done and then you think
about it you say well how can I do it
better and that starts the creativity
process as quickly as when somebody
drops that puzzle in your lap and you
don't care about it and then you start
working and then you can't see anything
else and when you see things that don't
work for example you're getting into a
car and windshield wipers smearing okay
don't think geez what a miserable design
that it I wanted you instead I wonder
how it could be done better if you try
to do something better it's impossible
to do anything better that you haven't
done differently okay if it's not
different it's impossible to be better
the universe isn't exactly true and we
see a lot of examples of that but but if
you do something better it will always
be different and if you simply decide
that and the other thing is that that
you're going to do it better you will
start those the mind going and you wait
how do you know if it's working how do
you know that if your mind really is
working that when you start getting
things in the middle of the night you
wake up you get an idea or you're
shaving or doing something and you get
an idea you're driving you get an idea
that's when that I am convinced that's
when that process is working if you
don't get any of that you really haven't
had the desire to do something that's
different and better everybody can do it
that's what you've got to get that
mechanism going and it's not hard it
really isn't time I once asked we Weiner
when we were walking from the from the
Faculty Club into the parking lot one
day I said how come you've made such
contributions in so many different
fields and he answered in just two words
he said insatiable
reality he always was wondering why or
how you could do something better that's
the key in all of this so focus on this
kind of thing don't worry about all the
things that you think are in necessary
in life and they'll come the money
everything else I never have worried one
day about anything like that when I
didn't have any money or when I did
I've never even decided my own salary in
this company ever firm outside to make
surveys things go well and you have all
those things none of those will bring
happiness by the way you've been told
that since you're a little kid but I can
guarantee that you have pretty wide
circle of people and that doesn't bring
it what brings it is your satisfaction
of doing something that's really
exciting and better and you can all have
that and you're all in a super position
to get it well
lest I lose my job here right in closing
I will simply share with you feeling
that I've had for quite a number of
years and that is every quite frankly
every September rolls around and I say
oh my god why did I commit to teaching
this fault how am I ever gonna fit this
in my schedule I know you know it looks
like a huge load coming on and every
December I look at the class and I say
I'm it's a funny kind of thing by the
way you you I don't know many of you at
all but you feel that you do you come
into the same room regularly you see the
same faces even if you just scan them it
becomes like a big family and every time
that December rolls around I sort of
feel sad that the thing is finishing and
it causes me and it has caused me for
many many years
to say oh I'll do it just once
it always has happened and it happens
again now in December so you're no
different and I thank you for that
experience all the best
you